[Music]
I'm not sure you'd believe me even if I
told you but bad shits happening that
people are going to take down the city
people are going to get hurt and decides
to stop you want to feel safe I have an
idea why don't you put on a cape and go
run around New York at the end of the
second season of that what matters kind
of lost
he's given up being this severity
Matthew this other wife you've learned
as your heart still were there but deep
down he genuinely believes the city is
better off with him
you have interrupted a citywide
investigation Jessica's never wanted to
be involved to some want to save the
city she doesn't care
Jessica Jones who the hell are you My
name is Matthew Murdock I'm your
attorney Paige is out of prison and he's
just trying to figure out was he with
his life right now I just want to help
people I think there's something that
you need to meet everything leads them
back to New York who you who are you I'm
the immortal artist you what now the
very existence of New York is it's taken
before of us saw a path to the same
place Midland sir
you look like an [ __ ]
your scarf
who are you people that an ancient
criminal organization whose goal is
ultimate power I can't be a part of this
if you asked me you already are these
people are incredibly dangerous they're
incredibly evil it's clear to them that
the only chance they have of saving New
York is gonna be if they work together
you for the devil of Hell's Kitchen the
smartass detective the righteous X Cohen
and the kid with a glowing fish see all
four of these characters together is
epic
thus for coming together will be
thrilling for fans of all the shows it
looks awesome
it feels also we can easily turn our
backs and just try and like take care of
ourselves but it's not about us
that's what being a hero is people who
run from the fire
they're people who run into it
you'll get used to watching them fall
nice ears their horns the thing about
war is it only works if both sides to
leave they're the good guys the truth is
we're not so different we fight to get
back what was once ours
[Music]
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall I think we're safe for now we
need to figure out our next vote felt
there's no next move and there is no
weed what is that
we're not here to eat those pork none on
the shrimp
oh this guy's got pork god you're weird
I'm not looking for Super Friends that
doesn't matter
can't fight these people not even with
whatever it is you're Hank to do it's
cheap it's
they're hunting our friends our family
and I'm not gonna stop there
more gases coming
and the only thing keeping Manhattan for
crumble into a pile of dust was the four
of you the wars for New York it's over
not yet
[Music]
eyes ears horns
I can see you've formed a kind of pond
I promise he was temporary
[Music]
by traffic they will disappoint you
Jessica like or not
they're together
that we found each other I'm not hugging
you it's been a long week
[Music]